well the images you just saw are
embarrassing and awkward for the liars
you've been watching on television for
the past month the ones who've been
lecturing you that the caravan doesn't
exist and telling you that everything is
just fine at the border the president
along with his favorite TV network were
beating the drum on the looming
so-called invasion as they put it the
programming on the caravan was
propaganda it was political campaign
motivated propaganda
Trump is like a racist Paul Revere you
know the migrants are coming the
migrants are coming he keeps calling it
an invasion yes an invasion of strollers
he made news by ratcheting up the
caravan scare talk and the troop numbers
he believes are needed to meet this
alleged threat this so-called invasion
so people are streaming over the border
illegally what would you call it I don't
know you're not allowed to call it
anything actually this is a recurring
theme on the Left don't believe your own
eyes you're too dumb to trust your own
senses listen to the smart kids they
know best there's no crisis on the
border even as hundreds of thousands of
people stream into this country every
year
illegally there's no illegal immigration
crisis yeah there are 22 million people
living here illegally it's not a crisis
it's not real they'll tell you that on a
loop endlessly until the day they retake
power at which point they'll say the
crisis is real in fact it's so enormous
we can only solve it by granting blanket
amnesty to all the people here illegally
there are 22 million after all what else
can we do this is a metaphor really for
the left's entire program which is built
entirely on denying reality they deny
the reality of illegal immigration they
deny the reality of terrorism they deny
the reality of biological gender and woe
to the person who raised his hand and
tries to insert reality into the
conversation they don't want that when
you have a program built entirely on
denial and deception it's not surprising
you're also against free speech you
can't afford to have an honest
conversation we'd like to have an honest
conversation that's why we're speaking
tonight to brian dean right he's a
democrat at a former CI officer and he
joins us on set so um i think there are
arguments in favor of letting these
people in even illegally that that's a
real position sure and maybe you can
make the case it's good for America it's
good for our economy maybe you think
it's bad for American you want it anyway
I mean all kinds of arguments but what's
not an argument is telling me that I'm a
racist for acknowledging the reality of
what is happening and that's the
position I'm seeing on television you're
correct so here's what we should be
starting with this conversation facts
right we typically don't right so the
facts tell us that first generation
immigrants are a net drain on our
economy
second that then eventually third
generation become net contributors
that's the fact right right secondarily
we know that the folks who are coming
across a border one to two thousand
people each day again having kids then
in a year or two years down the road
we're talking hundreds of thousands of
people all told that those folks are
initially anyway a burden to our economy
now well not they contribute something
many years down the road that is an open
question we should be able to have this
conversation irrespective of our poverty
affiliation and come to a conclusion
when we say look we need to have a
thoughtful strong border prevent some of
these folks from come across and if we
don't shame on us as a country well I
agree with that I mean I do think as you
just said that this is in many ways an
economic question and I don't understand
how you can look at the projections for
what automation is about to do to our
economy eliminating a huge percentage of
all low-skilled labor all low-skilled
labor in this country and say what we
need is more low-skilled labor how can
you make that argument you can the top
ten jobs that we see immigrants take
both legal and illegal make less than 20
bucks an hour which by the way the Obama
administration said jobs earning less
than 20 bucks an hour are going to be
automated into obsolescence so the
argument that we need an increasing
number of poorly qualified you know
folks who don't speak English don't
write have the skill sets that really we
need for the coming economy or frankly
the one that's already here that's
that's a silly argument it's just it
doesn't hold water so I always want to
believe the best about people and that
they have honorable motives and I think
most people do have honorable motives
but if you can't even marshal an
economic argument in favor of your
immigration policy I'm left believing
maybe it's only about getting more votes
for your party how cynical
I don't want to be cynical I just don't
I just don't see any other rationale
look I I appreciate the argument I think
you may be correct there are definitely
some parts that of the party and make no
mistake about it they want open borders
I mean just the other day I think it was
yesterday in fact senator Gillibrand
from New York was buddy-buddy with the
guy Sean McElwee who wants to remove the
border between the United States and
Mexico all right so there is an element
within this country not just in the
activist community but in fact within
the the left of this nation my own party
I I hate to say who want open borders
and that of course then feeds into this
issue
well what not only how do we take care
of them but ultimately who are they
gonna vote for and that there is a play
there that I think one could could argue
that this is a political play this is
about vote so I think it's fair to have
that that concern in that fear if I hear
one more [ __ ] on cable news cry racism
when somebody tries to have an honest
conversation about what this means I
swear I'm getting rid of my television I
mean I don't like it can't handle yeah
fine D right thank you very much always
great to see you